former manchester united footballer ryan
geeks will go on trial in manchester
next year accused of assaulting and
controlling his ex-girlfriend
a warning the next pictures do contain
some flash photography
he appeared at manchester crown court
this morning where his trial date was
set
mr giggs denies charges which include
assaulting kate gravel and ish using
controlling and coercive behavior
towards her during their relationship
our correspondent israel rashid has the
latest from manchester
this morning ryan giggs arriving at
manchester crown court he was
in court room six in the dock where he
uh once again
was facing those charges and it came to
a conclusion that he would be
on trial next year 24th of
january is when that trial date has been
fixed for it was only a brief 15 minute
hearing arrived in a
in a blue shirt this time without a face
mac as mask as opposed to
a couple of weeks ago where his face was
covered up and it's alleged that ryan
giggs 47 year old former
manchester united star he was then made
the interim manager when he retired for
manchester united
it's alleged that he assaulted his
ex-girlfriend kate
greville and caused her actual bodily
harm at his home
in greater manchester on the 1st of
november last
year there's also another charge of
coercive
and controlling behavior that's between
towards his ex-girlfriend between
december 2017
and november 2020 namely that he used
violence isolation belittling
humiliation harassment
degradation and abuse that was all
highlighted
at his first hearing at manchester
magistrates court a few
weeks ago and he's also charged with
common assault
by beating off his ex-girlfriend's
younger sister
emma greville in the same incident on
the 1st
of november so no plea hearing
today that's expected later in july and
of course that trial
is expected in january now previously
ryan giggs
has denied all these allegations he
believes that he is
not guilty to these allegations and
these charges and i'm sure we'll hear
more when he returns
to court for that plea hearing in july
but right now he remains
on bail with conditions that he must not
contact his ex-girlfriend kate revel
and her sister emma greville but leaving
court today
um and he will return for another
hearing in july and then the trial
in january 2022.
well it's been a difficult few days for
the government since former downing
street advisor dominic cummings accused
ministers
of falling disastrous disastrously short
of the standards the public has a right
to expect